welche und das interessiert unsere
Zuschauer auch weil sie es tatsächlich
auch gefragt haben klug welche
Konsequenzen hat es eigentlich wenn eine
Regierung ein so vernichtendes Urteil
aus aus Karlsruhe hört gibt's da Strafen
Strafen gibt's nicht auch keine
strafzahlen das Verfassungsgericht lebt
davon dass die Urteile respektiert
werden und die Strafe ist im Grunde das
was wir gerade erleben dass Politik
dafür sorgen muss dass das Urteil
respektiert wird und dass die Vorgaben
eingehalten werden das heißt dass man
Nachtragshaushalt macht dass man Geld
besorgt das ist die Strafe vielleicht
Strafen die Wähler auch am Ende die
Ampel dafür ab das ist Demokratie dass
ein Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts
respektiert wird und
das wir hten ehrlich gesagt ein ganz
anderes Problem wenn wenn Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts nicht respektiert
wden aber da sind wir bei weitem nicht
äh von daher ähm spricht das
Verfassungsgericht durch seine Urteile
und braucht keine
[Musik]
Strafen